Hi and welcome to The Winning Factor. I'm Alan Aitken and on this show each week
大家好，歡迎收聽《致勝因素》。我是艾倫·艾特肯，本節目每週為您帶來……
we take a look at some upcoming races in Hong Kong, try to identify an angle to
我們將檢視香港即將舉行之賽事，嘗試找出切入點。
the race that might lead us to finding the winner. Well it's Saturday racing
這場可能揭曉勝者的賽事，將於星期六進行。
this weekend in Hong Kong and the first race I'm going to take a look at is race
本週末於香港，首場賽事我將關注的是第幾場。
10 where our winning factor is the map. So this is class 3 1600 meters and
第十場，我們的致勝因素是地圖。此役為三級賽 1600 米，目前……
And Blazing Wukong and Amazing Partners are coming off last start wins.
「烈火悟空」與「驚奇拍檔」於上一場賽事勝出後，今仗再戰。
Endured has been racing well in similar events without much luck.
「Endured」在類似賽事中表現不俗，但始終未能取勝。
Smart Avenue should improve with a better draw.
智道有望憑藉更佳的起跑表現而提升。
And Family Jewel and Hymnbook both look to have chances as well.
而「Family Jewel」與「Hymnbook」亦均具機會。
So not a one horse race by any means.
因此，這絕非一場單騎獨進的賽事。
Quite a few chances.
機會相當多。
But I'm looking most closely at a couple of horses I think will cope with what looks quite a tricky event in terms of the map.
不過我主要關注數匹馬，認為牠們應付這個看似頗具挑戰性的地圖賽事不成問題。
And that's Blazing Wukong and Amazing Partners.
此為《火雲猴王》與《驚奇夥伴》。
Now, Amazing Partners, first of all, well, he's lightly raced.
現在，Amazing Partners，首先，其出賽次數較少。
He's only had six starts for three wins.
他至今僅出賽六場，取得三場勝利。
And this was his latest when he tackled 1,600 metres for the first time.
這正是他首次挑戰一千六百公尺時的最後一役。
This is race 601. He's in gate four pink colours.
此為第 601 場賽事，他位於四號閘，身穿粉紅色賽衣。
And Amazing Partners jumps well. He isn't a quick horse naturally.
Amazing Partners 跳躍能力出色，但天生並非速度型賽駒。
But Vincent Ho is able to get him into a position near the lead
但何秉遠成功將其帶至接近領先位置。
through what is a slow first sectional
首節比賽節奏緩慢。
before the pace does pick up a little through the middle stages,
在賽段中段速度稍為提升之前，
but still is only steady.
但始終僅屬平穩。
A number of Saturday's rivals are here too.
本週六的若干對手亦已蒞臨。
In Jude, inside amazing partners in red and grey,
朱德，令人驚嘆的紅灰配色馬匹。
Mr Dapper, the leader, and Himbuk in green near the tail.
達珀先生為領頭馬，身著綠色服裝的欣布克則位於尾部附近。
Now, the field is bunched here with no serious pace
現時賽場上馬羣聚集，未能展開有效步速。
and becomes just a dash down the straight,
並成為直道上的標誌點，
with in Jude on the inside having no luck.
猶德在內部毫無運氣。
But amazing partners, well, he's able to be challenging
但令人驚嘆的夥伴，他確實能帶來挑戰。
at the right time with enough turn of foot
在恰當時機展現足夠的靈巧步伐
to reel in the leaders and he grinds out the win.
他成功吸引領導層加入，並穩紮穩打贏得勝利。
Now, despite his good winning record, three from six amazing partners,
現時，儘管其勝出率理想，且擁有三位從六場比賽中表現出色的搭檔，
I don't really think we've seen the best of him yet
我並不認為我們已見識到他最出色的一面。
because he's been in several of these kinds of races
因其曾參加多次同類賽事。
where it's just a grinding sort of finish,
那是一種類似研磨的表面處理。
difficult to get separation on the field.
在場上難以取得分離效果。
So he's done well to put that record together
他成功籌組了該紀錄片。
and that could be a key thing in Saturday's race.
這或許是星期六賽事的一個關鍵因素。
Now, Blazing Wukong, on the other hand,
另一方面，現正進行的《烈焰悟空》。
He's a little bit more well explored with 11 starts so far for three wins.
他已較多出賽，至今十一場勝出三場。
And here's his latest offering.
此乃其最新推出之作。
This is race 643.
此為第 643 場賽事。